[Music]
humor me look to your left look to your
right what do you see you see smiling
people right there happily eating there
and their dinner I got 10 minutes
convince you that you're actually wrong
what you see is basically a whole bunch
of microbes are held together by bachi
human cells and so I'm gonna try and do
that so there's been this amazing new
technologies that come on in science as
loud as actually start to understand
these two microbes and what I want to
convince you is that basically you're
more my chrome than you are human so
where do we start with star story
well we already heard the 50 hunters I
can't go back that far I'm going back to
1683 Anthony van Leeuwenhoek he's
beavering away he's gonna make the very
first microscope he does this and like
any good scientist what I was look at
now so he reaches into his mouth scrapes
out his mouth holds it up into a little
microscope he sees all these little
Wiggly things he called animal chills
and he made the stunning observation
there were more these things in his
mouse mouth and all the people lived in
the Netherlands and thus we then
basically have the birth of what we now
call microbiota so it used to be called
normal flora and you know what flora
means so we had to change the name so we
changed to microbiota and really this is
just the definition of all the microbes
the bacteria viruses the single-celled
eukaryotic cells that live in and on us
and that when I say the word Mike your
boat and that's what I mean so I'm
talking about all the bugs that are on
you okay so this is where it gets really
interesting and it's a bit a bit
disheartening when you think you're
human we send you reeling cause these
things there's actually 10 times more
microbial cells in and on you than there
are human cells so I tell my students
you're ten times more microbes and you
are humans they don't like that so much
you encode a hundred these microbes and
150 times more genetic genes
then the human chromosome so they have
this huge genetic potential of living in
and on you and we now sort of basic call
the collection of the microbes and the
human together basically a super
organism because they're really a
collection of both these things we kind
of tend to think now these things as an
organ
they basically weigh about one and a
half kilograms basically the same sizes
and brain and that's the weight of these
microbes in and on us so where are they
well basically there were ever the
bodies exposed to the environment so on
the skin the genital tract for example
and most commonly in the
gastrointestinal tract basically as you
go down the GI tract there gets more and
more seeing large intestine there's
phenomenal numbers of these microbes in
there so what do all these critters
actually do well they actually do good
things this lovely dinner you're reading
you're basically not eating it for
yourself you're feeding your microbes
you're drinking for your microbes right
they make essential vitamins we know
that they basically make things that we
need to live but despite all this we
basically ignored these critters for the
last three hundred and twenty five odd
years since leaving hook discovered
these things we know where they're we
just couldn't do anything with them they
need oxygen to grow so you can't just
basically streak these things out on a
plate can make them grow they won't we
couldn't do that they're really hard to
grow so then sequencing came along you
all know about genome sequencing the
amazing power of sequencing the human
genome etc and I like to say that when
the human genome sequencer is finished
sequencing the human genome they looked
each other so what do we sequence next
and someone had the bright idea well
let's go after microbes because there's
an infinite number infinite number of
these things well we'll never have a
lots of job well always have something
to sequence so we can do that by
basically going after chunks these
microbes there's some conserved regions
in these genes called 16s ribosomal
genes and you can basically put primers
on these concern reasons and then
amplify up the regions that are
different between these microbes in
between and once you have that sequence
you can basically use that to put them
on sort of the Tree of Life
and basically identify which microbes
they are without ever growing them and
then we can now do this quite a lot
these days and we can now do this so now
we can actually identify what all the
microbes are based on this sequencing in
an honest
and each of you we have between 500 and
thousand microbial species happily
living in your gut saying feed me more
please as the night goes on and so the
other neat thing is we're all different
homo sapien genes are 99.99 percent
identical were very similar except for
their like chromosomal difference
between male and female but we each have
a unique set of microbial species that
makes us actually quite unique so in the
past five years this has been a very
very active area of research and it's
just really changing the whole landscape
in many areas in biology what we are
realizing the micro play a key role in
both on normal development and disease
we know they're absolutely essential for
immune system developed properly we have
things called germ-free animals is
basically microbe free animals their
immune systems don't develop and even
more stunningly their brains don't
develop normally they don't need those
microbes to allow their brain to develop
and you'll see that will come in later
however there's a dark side to these
creators too and what we're finding is
these microbes are playing a role in
many diseases that we are on that we
commonly thought were sort of a 21st
century developed country diseases this
curve is my favorite curve on the left
as infectious diseases they're all going
down over the last 50 years that makes
sense right we've cleaned up the water
we've got vaccines etc and I work on
infectious diseases so I took one look
at this curve and said I better find
something else to work on so I'm gonna
go work on the right-hand side of that
curve there and on that curve this is
only 50 years look at the stunning rises
in MS multi-row says Crohn's disease
type 1 diabetes asthma it's just going
through the roof and the question is why
and ironically we're starting to realize
the microbes are playing a big role as
we shift our a world we live in and
these microbes are contributing to it so
I'll just take a slight detour and tell
you about some exciting work we're now
doing on asthma
you know asthma is one of those ones
it's just going through the roof when I
was a kid no one had asthma now I go to
a playground basically the kid runs up a
slide shares his puffer with his
neighbor's kid who runs up the slide and
you know a quarter of all kids have
asthma how come we haven't genetically
changed in that period and lab and work
in our lab and others are now with
activities profoundly showing that the
gut microbiota are actually affecting
how our immune system develops
which translates to asthma we've now
identified bugs that we think are
protective to this so we actually have a
joke in this field in the micro boda
field what isn't caused by the
microbiota not that we have egos or
anything and so the world is working
feverishly in all these areas and then
it's just all sorts of cool that is
coming out every day in this area so
that takes us to the sea far ground what
are we gonna do that's big bold and etc
so this is the title of a microbes in
humans the role of Michael Bowen in
human development evolution and society
so as I said there's a lot of people
working individual diseases etc and as
well health but this sea far like all
CFR programmes wants to go way beyond us
to boldly go where no human has gone
before basically we're going to take
this really outside the box type idea
and venture into really an uncharted
unexplored area and of course this could
really only be done under the confines
of a CFR type program because if I wrote
this grant anywhere else there's no way
that as such a bold and innovative and
rather interesting idea would ever get
funded so we're now just realize the
microphone has a profound effect on
human development and actually even our
behavior so we need to rethink how we
think of ourselves and really we're a
collection of us and our microbes I'm
trying to convince you this this is
something called the holo genome that's
where all the microbes genes and our
genes as well so you're born you have a
set of DNA you are going to die with
that DNA as hard as you try you're not
going to evolve in a lifetime you can't
do that basically your DNA doesn't
change but what about all the bugs in an
honest these things change rapidly we
know and child are they change in
pregnancy they change no old age they
change these microbes are changing so
your genic potential is actually
changing even though Homo sapiens DNA
isn't it so that brings up some really
interesting concepts for example what
happens in their plague it's in the
micros best interest to keep us alive
right or pandemic so maybe they change
allow us to live through this and
genetically we as Homo sapiens and then
catch-up generations down the line so
one of the neat concepts we have is we
have someone is basically digging up
skulls and Italian graveyards going back
to the fourth century and you can scrape
both the dental plaque and you can then
amplify the bugs and you correlate how
do those correlate
when say pandemic plagues roared through
that particular village and we can
correlate this and see these changes
going on
so even twin studies say that there's
that what we call a heritable microbiome
when a mother and when a kid is born the
mother passes on the maternal genes and
and paternal genes to that kid right
well they also pass on the microbes
we're actually passing on these microbes
as sort of a genetic type inheritance to
these things so this this area is going
to tackle these three big areas and I'm
just going to briefly go through each of
these
so human development we now realize I
was always taught the the fetus was
sterile
we now realize that's not there's
actually microbes there and we also know
that the microbes and the gut make all
these metabolites that go into the feces
and actually affect development early
childhood there's all sorts of stunning
results coming out the microbiota play a
big role in how we develop in childhood
I've already told you about the immune
system and even brain development are
there bugs that affect IQ we don't know
this we were going to go looking
so that's development and there's the
evolution so we're now starting get a
little more risk in terms of concepts
here can the microbiota prey a role in
human evolution I've already described
this whole or genome concept that these
microbes can basically give you an
enhanced fitness and they can adapt to
the changing environment which basically
allows us to evolve more and rapid
changes to environment environmental
stress and changes can actually be used
by these microbes could we have a
selfish microphone this is actually
driving our evolution we think we're
evolving as humans may be the microbes
have a grander plan and they're saying
no we should evolve to go eat Big Macs
and make my microbes really happy and
and things like this maybe it's an
interesting concept and then the third
area is society and if I ever thought I
was gonna stand up in front of people
didn't talk about microbes and their
effect on society I
I never envisioned that one so you know
can the microbes actually affect
anthropology we know the microbiota can
affect behavioural changes with us we
know so at least in mice we know that
you can actually change the behavior of
mice by altering the microbiota could
they change a human behavior we change
our eating habits
we change our microbes do they change us
all sorts of societal effects
breastfeeding for example changer
microbes versus bottle-fed cesarean
sections versus vaginal delivery caused
drastic changes in the microbiota this
actually affect how we evolved as a
society antibiotic use fermented foods
these all impact on microbes which may
actually affect us as we evolve as a
society and of course there's cultural
changes and these things impact on the
microbes which may then have an effect
on society so this is obviously a very
interdisciplinary type thing which is
going to occur expertise from all sorts
of people so it's a really interesting
new area it's a boulder you no one's
ever gone in this area before we're
gonna learn a lot about human
development from what the microbes do
this isn't everything looked at before
and even evolution in this whole new
light and you know then we'll come to
the realization the microbes may
actually affect our evolution and even
future evolution of our societies in in
this role so we're gonna need a whole
bunch of expertise I and some of the
people recruit include like social
anthropologists people working on
primate behavior etc social historians
if I ever thought I'd be talking to a
social historian you say it crazy but
they come to play in this so you know I
think this group will be a really
interesting group to get together the
other nice thing is that it's gonna
impact closely with other seafood
programs already funded there's a child
and brain development well you can see
the analogies there because we're now
realizing micros play a role in in brain
development and there's another program
called integrated microbial diversity
they study microbes in different
environments while the human is just a
different environment so there's
obviously parallels there so I really
think it's a really transform our
concepts of biology and human evolution
with all sorts of impacts on potential
in humanity so I started the talk with
you looking at each of your neighbors
here so as I conclude here have another
look did it look the same just see any
microbes on these guys thank you very
much
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]